Vsauce! Kevin here, with a game that gives
you quantifiable, verifiable strength against
your opponents and even the advantage of going
first. Simple math and logic conspire to delude
you into believing that the odds are in YOUR
favor -- but in the long run I'm gonna win
every time. And even when you understand how
this paradox works, you STILL probably won't
be able to rationalize it.
It goes like this: I’ve got four different
dice, and I’ve replaced their regular sides
of 1-6 with different combinations of numbers.
Here are some maps to make it easier to see.
A has 4’s and 0’s, B has all 3’s, C
has 2’s and 6’s, and D has 5’s and 1’s.
You choose one and I’ll choose one. We roll
and the highest number wins. And because I’m
so nice -- I’m gonna let YOU choose the
best die first.
WHICH IS THE BEST?
The simplest, safest way to choose the best
one is to add up the sides and take the highest
total. C has a total of 20. Those 2’s aren’t
great, but the 6’s beat anything. C seems
like the best overall choice. B and D each
add to 18 and A only has 16.
But if you choose C, I’ll choose B -- and
I’m gonna win most of the time. LOOK. Here’s
a table of all the possible rolls both of
us can have. Of the 36 possible combinations
of rolls, B comes out on top 24 times to C’s
12. You’ve chosen what looks like the best
die, and I’ll still beat you 2 out of 3
times.
Okay. So. Just adding up the sides isn’t
good enough, so maybe you factor in standard
deviation on the sides of the dice… hold
on... hold on... I’m gonna give you a game-changing
hint. Here it is:
A beats B. B beats C. and C beats D. These
charts account for every single roll in that
progression, and I’m showing you the data
to prove that A is at the top of a chain of
dominance.
You know that due to the transitive property,
if A beats B and B beats C, then A should
also beat C. And if C beats D, then A and
B should beat D, too. It’s like lining people
up by height, if A is taller than B and B
is taller than C, then A has to be taller
than C. Makes sense. Right?
Alright. Let’s play again -- and it sounds
like you want to choose A this time? Because
it beats everything? Because I literally just
showed you that the transitive property makes
A better than B, C and D, RIGHT? WRONG! If
you choose A, I’m gonna take the WORST choice
at the very END of the ‘greater than’
chain. I’m choosing D to go against your
A, and I’m going to crush you with my D.
How?
Before I explain I must tell you this video
is SPONSORED BY ME.
Some make tools for home improvement.
We make tools for DOME improvement.
Puzzles, Physics Toys, Experiments, Smart
Steam games, Exclusive Vsauce shirts, amazing
science books and a lot more. With a Curiosity
Curriculum to explain the science and activities
behind it all. The Curiosity Box is a seasonable
subscription box made by us for you. So to
do some dome improvement and add wrinkles
to your brain go to CuriosityBox.com. Our
20th box is shipping right now. Click the
link below. Let Vsauce into your home.
Okay so here’s why I’m choosing the worst
die to beat your best -- wait. These dice
are too easy. So many numbers repeat that
it’s elementary -- and you’re a genius.
Let’s use another set of numbers from 0
to 12. This set has the same property as the
easier ones, A is better than B, B is better
than C, and C is better than D. If we get
a tie, we’ll just roll again. You choose
A, the strongest die.
I want the weakest die because… it’s actually
not.
D is at the losing end of our chain, and my
D die is still going to win nearly ⅔ of
the time against your strong A. Which seems
impossible but let’s test it!
So despite D seeming to be the weakest and
A being the strongest, out of 15 tolls, D
won exactly twice as many times as A. D is
somehow stronger than A. In this game, no
matter WHAT die you choose, I’m gonna beat
you twice as often as you beat me -- even
with the A > B > C > D chain of dominance,
I am ALWAYS going to pick a better die.
Because these dice aren’t transitive. These
are Efron’s Dice. Here’s the proof: My
voice cracked. Who cares? Math!
These charts reveal the truth about the matchups
in our 0-12 dice, and I’ve labeled the squares
that each die wins. Just like I said, A beats
B around ⅔ of the time, and it’s the same
for B vs. C and C vs. D.
But let’s look at D vs. A -- despite being
worse against C, which is worse than B, which
is worse than A, D is actually STRONGER than
A. Which makes NO SENSE... IT MAKES NO SENSE.
But it’s mathematically true.
Bradley Efron is a statistician who has won
just about every award in the statistics game
over the last 60 years. And he’s still going
-- in 2018 he won the International Prize
in Statistics, which is basically the Nobel
Prize of stats. And he invented what we now
call Efron’s Dice -- sets of dice that are
maddeningly nontransitive, and that nontransitivity
is cloaked so carefully that it’s almost
impossible to grasp even when you know it’s
true.
If you choose D? Fine, I’ll just choose
C, which we know beats D most of the time.
If you choose B? I can choose A and win a
lot more than I lose.
C? I choose B. A? I choose D. You literally
have NO WAY to win this game in the long term,
because I can ALWAYS choose a die that’s
better than yours -- even if you choose the
best die first.
And that’s the veridical paradox here -- how
can you have the best possible choice that…
isn’t? How can a die prove it’s the strongest
and then LOSE to the weakest? How can a die
verifiably lose to everything except when
it’s up against the one it SHOULDN’T be
able to win against?
The problem isn’t the dice. It’s us.
We fall into a cognitive trap of thinking
in absolute terms when real value is often
relative. In this game, the concept of better
or worse is deceptive -- it depends completely
on the situation. Our brains, especially when
it comes to numbers, want to sort patterns
and construct algorithms and employ heuristics
that identify the best choice. And we LOVE
ranking things, whether it’s music or sports
or cereal tier lists.
But… life isn’t always transitive. And
if you get stuck thinking in absolutes, you’re
gonna get duped by the gamemaster who knows
when the real value lies in the relative -- and
they’re gonna win most of the time.
SO UNSTICK YOUR BRAIN.
And as always -- thanks for watching. I was
gonna throw these at the camera. But that
would be bad. So. There.